Speaker 1: We are now getting the expert testimony
of the not smartest son of the former President
Donald Trump.
I'm talking about Eric Trump.
Eric Trump went on Fox News's Hannity program
to try to defend his dad and attack Joe Biden
on the topic of Ukraine.
And now at this point, it sort of seems pointless
in the sense that Joe Biden has an almost
60 percent approval on his handling of Ukraine,
which in a country as polarized as the United
States when 60 percent of the country believes
are doing a good job.
That's pretty overwhelming.
Sadly, in this polarized state of affairs,
Trump never had 60 percent approval on anything
that he oversaw while he was president.
And they clearly know what they're trying
to run interference for Trump.
But remember, Trump withheld military aid
to Ukraine, hoping it would force Zelensky
to start providing dirt on Joe Biden.
Thanks to that little strategy being outed,
Trump ultimately had to release the military
aid to Ukraine.
So anyway, Eric Trump talks to Sean Hannity,
and it's all completely crazy.
It's a delusional fantasy world understanding
of how Trump and foreign policy co-existed,
and this is the Trumpian sort of analysis
that counts as analysis in their world in
which they live.
Speaker 2: Listen, my father would call up
and he would have said, Vladimir, don't even
think about it.
Don't even try us.
I'm telling you, it's not going to work out
very well for you, right?
Speaker 1: So this is the idea that Trump
was really, really tough on Putin and that
Putin respected Trump.
Now you can say a lot of things about Putin.
I don't think he really cares about the welfare
of individual Russians.
He cares about, you know, furthering his plans
for a sort of new USSR.
And that's his priority.
Putin's ruthless and brutal.
He disappears.
Dissidents, he disappears, you know, disappears.
And by that, I mean kills and sometimes unjustly
imprisons media people who don't agree.
You can say all that stuff about Putin.
But Putin is way smarter than Trump.
There is no doubt about that.
And there is no way in hell that Putin was
intimidated in any way by Donald Trump.
Let's go to the next clip.
Speaker 2: By the way, my father had a great
relationship with Putin.
We know all the while he's sending thousands
of javelin missiles to the Ukraine.
Is that really made, by the way,
Speaker 1: they still are on the Ukraine thing?
I mean,
Speaker 2: Biden has no relationship with
Putin, and he's literally sending blankets
for Ukraine.
It's, you know, again, Sean, it's
Speaker 1: so these are, of course, lies Biden
and the U.S. has have sent significant military
aid to Ukraine.
Remember that the aide, Eric Trump is referring
to his dad sending was aid that Trump initially
withheld because he was trying to push Zelensky
to announce that they were investigating Joe
and Hunter Biden.
He ultimately released the aid.
But again, importantly, a good relationship
with Putin comes when Putin sees that you're
a joke, when Putin sees that you're a patsy.
And that's exactly what Putin saw in Donald
Trump.
Here's one last clip of Eric Trump's incisive
and principled analysis of geopolitics by.
Speaker 2: Well, Mr. Putin was in with the
KGB.
He can read people and he could tell that
Donald Trump was a very strong person, right?
Speaker 1: Right.
No wrong.
And again, 90 percent of that sentence is
right.
Putin was in the KGB.
Putin can read people, and he can tell that
Donald Trump was a very weak person.
I mean, remember Trump coming out in Helsinki
and saying, Listen, I asked him, Did you hack
us?
Did you hack the U.S.?
And he said no, and he said it very strongly,
and I believe him.
That's what Putin signed.
Trump, Trump is a patsy, so nobody ever said
Eric was the smart one.
But now, just obviously, I mean, just laughably
unbelievable claims about Trump's handling
of geopolitics, foreign relations, Russia
and Ukraine.